les écoliers du nord pas de calais en
direct sur france bleu nord ce matin
deux heures d'antenne consacré au récent
attentat perpétré à new york est un
standard rapidement saturé par des
centaines d'appels émanant de toute la
région et que si on revient souvent les
mains est-ce qu'il va y avoir une très
longue guerre mondiale pourquoi les
passagers sont bas on va essayer
défendre ou les autres passagers au
poids des camions et des enfants des
bûches encore causé d'un côté quatre
spécialistes médecins professeurs
militaires et représentants des droits
de l'homme de l'autre des écoliers
intrigue est parfois à leur est souvent
concernés moi ce sont plutôt les
questions de peur qu'ils montrent qu'ils
m'ont vraiment touché les questions des
enfants qui ont très peur qu'ils ont
peur de la guerre on en parlait de
d'armes bactériologiques à les enfants
pauline ces termes là donc ils savent
que ça peut être très très grave
il fera laxisme c'est la croyance la
certitude d'être d'avoir raison sur tout
sept cent mille écoliers aurait ainsi
participé directement ou indirectement à
cette émission spéciale des enfants qui
aux dires des spécialistes invités sur
le plateau ont un besoin vital de mieux
comprendre ces événements qui ne les
laisse pas insensible